good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-6373
containment class
neutralized
previously
ketter assigned site area 179 site
director jay barrow research head jay
dune assigned task force non-applicable
special containment procedures the
building containing
scp-6373 has been outfitted with a
closed circuit surveillance system and
shuttered from public access
assigned personnel are to view and
transcribe
scp-6373's daily performances counseling
is available as a part of post-viewing
debriefing personnel are expected to be
repulsed
description
scp-6373 is a collection of four paper
mache puppets each one meter in height
chemical analysis indicates each
puppet's exterior is constructed from
non-anomalous material all attempts to
observe the interior of scp-6373
through either physical or endoscopic
means have failed all instances are
attached to an individual set of strings
bound together by a plastic cross-shaped
mechanism intended for control by a
puppeteer
scp-6373 emit a strong rotting odor
causing visceral nausea this response is
entirely non-anomalous
at 1800 hours daily
scp-6373 will gain anomalous properties
primarily limited sentience mobility and
intelligence attempts to interact with
objects outside of
scp-6373 events see below have failed
this event will not occur if
scp-6373 are contained in a location
other than the gawford theater located
in reading pennsylvania instead they
will remain inert objects
scp-6373 will then begin a rapid
deterioration process involving slowly
melting their paper mache bodies and
emitting a stronger more intensive odor
as a result this process continues until
scp-6373 are placed within a 12-meter
vicinity of the gofford theater
when conditions for animation are
sufficient
scp-6373 proceed to the main stage of
the theater to perform an act classify
it as an
scp-6373 event the details of this
performance are fluid and ever-changing
and presently no repeat performances
have been observed an audience of at
least one individual must be present at
the theater to observe the performance
otherwise
scp-6373 will undergo decomposition
scp-6370 event summary and cast
overview an
scp-6373 event is a largely unorganized
and spontaneous performance acted out by
scp-6373
featuring unorthodox attempts at humor
storytelling and entertainment audience
attempts to interact with
scp-6373 during a performance have
resulted in injury performances do not
have a set length ranging from two
minutes to three weeks in length
descriptions of each puppet's physical
appearance and typical role in an
scp-6373 event can be found below
scp-6373-1 is an elderly male with a
pointed nose and large eyes clad in a
beret black sweater and striped shirt
scp-6373-1 is referred to as pierre and
serves as the performance's host and
central character
scp-6373-2
is a large bald disembodied head with
sizable ears and an open-mouthed
expression
scp-6373-2 is referred to as glauten and
is incapable of speaking outside of deep
guttural moaning and single-word
statements
scp-6373-3 is a dominion of disembodied
head with closed sunken eyes and a
solemn expression it is noticeably
smaller than the others and its skin is
painted a discolored gray while the
puppet features no limbs much like
clouton audiences have observed that
strings being pulled during performances
as if articulated joints were present
scp-6373 is referred to as a may though
a may does not typically speak or make
noise it will on occasion silently cry
amay is the most frequent target of
pierre's verbal and physical abuse
scp-6373-4 is a long-necked clown
wearing an outfit typical of such with
white gloves
scp-6373-4 is the only puppet with a
hinged jaw intended to be operated
through the use of a string connected at
the bottom of the mouth this mechanism
has since broken rendering
scp-6373's jaw loose and uncontrollable
scp-6373-4 is referred to as jacques and
serves as the group's comic relief
jacques often reiterates the phrase
isn't that funny to punctuate its antics
addendum 6373-1
history and performance summaries
the gofford theater was opened in
reading pennsylvania in 1860 by french
immigrant and entrepreneur timothy
gofford the theater was host to stage
plays musical performances
and in-house puppet shows that featured
scp-6373
the puppets were personally designed by
gofford who maintained an intensive
interest in puppeteering and often
participated in the show's production
these shows were massively profitable
and popular among redding's children it
is unknown if
scp-6373 held any anomalous significance
during the theater's operation but
written evidence detailing payrolls of
puppeteers and printed copies of scripts
intended to be performed by scp-6373
suggests they were ordinary puppets
in 1884 the theater closed due to
embezzlement committed by gofford's wife
cynthia cordier cortier's actions were
presumably in retaliation to godford's
unfaithfulness in their marriage this
resulted in a divorce and subsequent
legal battle which gawford lost
in 1886 gofford wrote a letter to his
wife a portion of which has been
transcribed below
i write to you in poor health and all
joy sapped from my life may misfortune
follow you until the end of your days i
will not construct again that which i
had spent two decades of my life working
towards i can only thank god's grace
that the building has remained vacant as
i could not bear to see it owned by
another man i want to perform again and
see the children smile my happiness was
so linked to theirs
one week later goffer disappeared no
evidence of his whereabouts were found
the letter remains his last known
communication with another individual
records indicate cynthia cortier would
die of natural causes four months later
in 1887 the american secure containment
initiative discovered
scp-6373 during an inspection of the
building anomalous effects were
documented thereafter and containment
continued after the american secure
containment initiative had been
assimilated into the scp foundation
a log of notable
scp-6373 performances have been recorded
below
performance summary 1887 1022
first recorded performance lighting
fixtures around the theater collectively
power on several minutes before the show
and a slight piano accompaniment
originating from an unknown source is
heard throughout the event pierre
rescues a princess a costumed jacques
from a dragon played by glutton
researchers note several moments when an
scp-6373 instance has difficulty
maintaining posture and moving often
taking multiple attempts to lift limbs
these moments increase in frequency over
time
performance summary 1895-0417
pierre and the other puppets take the
roles of criminals recovering after a
botched bank robbery attempt as they
attempt to figure out who alerted the
police to their activities they come to
the conclusion that it was a may the
puppets spend the rest of the
performance using the spherical ma as a
ball in a game of soccer it eventually
devolves into a contest to see which
puppet can kikkamae the hardest pierre
berets mma for betraying its trust and
breaking the bond they had shared after
years of working together examination of
liquids secreted by a may puppet
indicates chemical similarity to human
tears
performance summary 1916 o2 29
the puppets reenact a scene on a farm
while the german russian conflict known
as the battle of tannenberg is waged
nearby glauten and jock take the role of
a german and russian soldier
respectively and act out a slapstick
battle in a field sounds of war and
human suffering are heard throughout the
subsequent scene inside the farmhouse
features pierre and may as a husband and
wife pierre laments that its crops have
been destroyed due to the war and calls
to a may for support the puppets remain
silent even as pierre's cries grow
louder and more frantic as it shifts the
blame of the crop's destruction from the
war to a may itself pierre states that a
may will never be let out again
presumably referring to the house
performance summary 1922 08 21
scp-6373 performed a similar narrative
as the first recorded
scp-6373 event audiences note each
puppet sounds discontented in its
delivery of dialogue movements do not
sync up with dialogue and instances move
in frantic bursts hanging limp when not
speaking the ending where pierre escapes
with jock while glouten flees is altered
instead pierre directly attacks glutton
with a plastic sword while berating the
puppet for being useless clouten acts as
if it were dead and pierre comments on
its acting stating that isn't what being
dead feels like
future
scp-6373 events are noticeably more
dissonant and aggressive in tone
performance summary 1938-1104
[Music]
first direct audience acknowledgement by
scp-6373
puppets engage in a comedic sketch
involving dancing instances move in slow
jerking motions while dialogue is
quickly paced pierre becomes frustrated
that the other puppets are unable to
synchronize themselves and suspects they
are being intentionally uncooperative
pierre brandishes a prop hose and sprays
water at the puppets this removes paint
from their bodies high-pitched feminine
screams are heard throughout the theater
with no discernible point of origin
pierre turns to the audience and states
it's always the same kids out there
performance ends with pierre hurling a
may into the crowd after it attempted to
roll off stage from this point on pierre
speaks to the audience while performing
usually to seek approval before berating
another puppet all paint was restored by
the next event future performances
frequently feature pierre accusing other
puppets of malfeasance and taking
physical action as a result
performance summary 1952 01 11.
pierre performs a piano duet with
jacques who is unable to be quiet or
still though jacques apologizes pierre
repeatedly slams the puppet's head into
the piano denting it when pierre is
finished viewers note jacques jaw has
detached completely jacques laughter
turns into paint cries as the puppet
takes damage within minutes viscous
yellow fluid begins to seep from jacques
as it fails to reattach its jaw audience
describe the liquid's odor as repugnant
pierre retrieves a may and forces the
puppet to sit in a puddle of the fluid
this event marks the beginning of a
trend towards increasingly violent
behavior while puppets sustain heavy
damage as a result they begin each
performance fully restored notably
jacques jaw is never fixed and the
fluids continue to seep from the puppet
performance summary 1958 03 30.
shortest performance two minutes in
duration pierre is teaching an art class
where each puppet is painting on a
canvas glauten's canvas displays the
words open inside when pierre sees this
it becomes infuriated and ends the event
leading the puppets off stage
scp-6373 instances disappear and are
unable to be located for the next 24
hours an unidentified male voice swears
and screams from behind the stage's
curtain punctuated by bouts of loud
banging and clattering the source is not
discerned lights remain powered on and
centered on the stage
scp-6373 re-emerged at 1800 hours the
following day for a routine performance
performance summary 1963 08 21
pierre takes the stage and berates the
audience for attending pierre asks if
the audience is aware that in death a
soul can still wither pierre's voice
changes to that of a woman's and
delivers a eulogy in memory of timothy
gawford later investigation revealed
that a funeral was not held for gofford
performance summary 1971
0606
performance is routine involving a
sketch where pierre teaches jacques how
to play baseball using a may as the ball
jacques is hesitant to hurt him a but is
pressured into doing so all dialogue is
delivered in a monotonous male voice as
opposed to their ordinary intonations
there are frequent pauses in size in
each puppet's delivery this voice
persists throughout all remaining
scp-6373 events movements during this
performance are notably more loose and
fluid than before when an instance
appears to have difficulty moving it
will strike itself restoring fluid
motion
performance summary 1973-0113
puppets wear large paper mache
facsimiles of human bodies and interact
with each other in a sitcom household
environment audience members report
hearing a faint laugh track in the
background though one is not present in
the recordings of the event over time
the suits begin to decompose layers of
paper mache slough off to reveal loose
viscera pierre frequently assaults a may
with various household objects and at
one point causes the puppet to split in
two after breaking it open with the
corner of the table pierre encourages
its two sons glouten and jock to
belittle or berate amay throughout
performance ends with glauten pushing a
cabinet of dinner plates on top of the
half destroyed of may
examination of material left on stage
following the event revealed it to be
bovine in composition excess blood fluid
and viscera remained on stage throughout
later performances and began to rot
removal was deemed
impossible performance summary 1976-0702
[Music]
scp-6373 does not take the stage instead
the event is projected onto the stage's
curtains by shadows their source is
unknown all puppets take part in
insulting may claiming that it is
responsible for their current situation
and it is the sole reason they are
unable to move forward
pierre prisamay's eyes open with a pair
of pliers
jacques spews fluid onto a may causing
the puppet to scream pierre forces
glouten to consume and regurgitate mma a
maze beaten with shovels drilled holes
into with a power tool and squeezed by a
vise to the point of breaking entirely
event lasts four hours uninterrupted
during this process the pierre puppet
emerges from behind the curtain and
attempts an ordinary performance of jack
and the beanstalk while the shadows of
jack and glauten continue to beat amay
all researchers attempts to open the mma
puppet's eyelids have failed
performance summary 1979 09
18. puppets retell and reenact the story
of timothy gawford's life framing him as
an individual who is treated unfairly by
society and his circumstances
performance concludes with pierre
stating that timothy gawford died alone
miserable
and never experiencing love there is no
mention of cynthia cortier throughout
the performance the puppet states that
the gofford theater remains timothy's
lasting legacy and thanks the audience
for their continued support pierre then
flagellates itself to the point of
knocking its head off its shoulders and
releasing a massive blowfly larvae from
its neck a feminine scream emerges from
the hole larvae are unable to be removed
from the stage except when it is
consumed by rats inhabiting the theater
performance summary 1979 09 18.
scp-6373
performed a retelling of hansel and
gretel all instances deteriorate
considerably seemingly without reason
puppets have mobility issues throughout
sometimes repeating actions several
times or falling to the ground the
performance is entirely silent until the
final scene where pierre and jock toss a
costumed glouten into a mock oven as the
puppet burns it states it cannot stay
together anymore all puppets collapse
observation of the gofford theater later
reveals that the structural integrity of
the building is in jeopardy due to
previously undiscovered infestation of
termites and wood decaying fungi in key
construction areas
performance summary 1983-0802
[Music]
scp-6373 instances hold a mock funeral
for a may and spend the rest of the
performance exploding various afterlifes
that the puppet may be delivered to
complete with props and costumes puppets
are notably culturally insensitive when
discussing non-western afterlifes event
concludes with shock commenting on the
excessive punitive afterlifes and that
it's impossible to truly know which a
person should believe in to achieve
salvation pierre then states it knows
the answer we're all dead this is the
only afterlife there is puppets then go
limp and remain in this state for a week
missing seven performances all future
performances lack props and costumes
marking a decline in performance effort
by scp-6373
performance summary 1984-03-18
pierre tells nonsensical jokes which
jacques and glouten laugh excessively at
pierre then goes on a tirade about
wanting to injure members of the
audience while performing and then asks
the crowd if they feel similar glutton
admits that it fantasizes about wanting
to break a child's arms every second
it's alive pierre then asks the audience
for a volunteer to demonstrate breaking
an arm the performance is silent for 46
minutes before researcher lang
volunteers herself pierre snaps lang's
arm at the elbow fracturing her ulna the
puppet cites her resemblance to that
as greatly increasing its enjoyment of
the act the performance ends lange is
reassigned to a different anomaly
following treatment future performances
infrequently include
scp-6373 committing acts of violence
towards a member of the audience
performance summary 1984 09 18
last performance with discernible
dialogue
event is composed entirely of pierre
stating the full name birth and
expiration date of every patron of the
gofford theater from its opening to
present
members of the audience are included in
this routine throughout the act pierre's
movements are awkward and its speech is
slow and slurred event concludes with
pierre looking to the ceiling stating
you carry on so well before violently
throwing itself across the stage
multiple times
performance summary 1985 02 12.
performances have degraded to frenzies
of self-harm carried out by each puppet
stage lighting is absent or flickers
musical accompaniment is discordant and
cacophonous instances self-mutilate
flagellate and flay themselves through
the use of the stage floor's friction
each other or blunt force trauma screams
range from high-pitched feminine voices
to deep male ones
occasional laughter is heard during male
screams
performance summary 1985-04-25
[Music]
all puppets sit on the stage motionless
occasionally turning their heads to
monologue to the audience in a
nonsensical indecipherable fashion
several researchers claimed the puppets
were directly gazing at them all future
dialogue and performances consist solely
of moaning grunting screaming and
weeping with extended periods of
inactivity physical actions are often
limited to standing or sitting
performance summary 1985-05-13
is entirely indecipherable
performance summary 1985-0609
final performance
scp-6373 instances stand side by side
for 18 minutes no dialogue is heard they
collectively bow and fall to the ground
stage lights and music cease no further
events occur see adenda for details
following the
1985-0609 performance all scp-6373
instances began the deterioration
process observed prior shedding their
paper mache exteriors when this was
complete each instance was discovered to
contain preserved human remains and
organs which had been segmented cleanly
at several termination points all
remains are presumably sourced from a
single individual their contents have
been listed below
pierre contained a brain
jacques contained a heart glauten
contained a conglomerate mass of excess
organs an unbroken layer of epidermal
skin tissue fecal matter and hair
a may was empty
examination of unfolded skin tissue
found within glauten revealed a
resemblance to person of interest
6373-2 cynthia cortier object has been
reclassified as neutralized
i'm just going to take this off the
screen
i hate puppets
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you're all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran
professor puffer
the morrigan
retalias
karim el ashmuy
nicholas hayes
gav the clumsy containment specialist
spooky aqua jaby
pure osmium
scio dio demnatas
revenant
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
eric corbeage
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you